[Music]
hey you guys here we are once again it's
monday
yeah monday yeah i guess it is monday we
have the same shirt on goddammit
well [ __ ] you know
they're just work shirts well [ __ ]
yeah i gotta i'll zip my little she just
noticed it now and then she told me yeah
well i didn't notice you weren't in here
yeah i didn't notice i wasn't looking at
your shirt it's all good
it doesn't matter you can't really i
made a [ __ ] ton of them
yeah we did make this this is actually
my favorite one that i did i think yeah
although i like that other one too like
the round one this little grim reaper i
like that one as well
all right we'll talk about this movie um
once again the koreans uh kind of
knocked it out of the park with this one
back in 2000 they did
i really you know
when i lived in korea
korean but this is back in the early
2000s late you know i guess it moved
there in freaking 199 and this used to
be 1990 is when i lived there 1991
towards the end of 91. and during that
time korean stuff [ __ ] sucked
it was always some kind of like japanese
knockoff of kind of inferior quality it
wasn't any good
um
and i think like
korean gen xers who were my age back in
those days were also noticing that
because that [ __ ] was made by korean
boomers
and it was just looking lame
so i
korean gen xers i think were noticing
that their [ __ ] storytelling kind of
sucked
so they started to kind of up the game i
remember the first
the first a couple korean movies that i
noticed and i was like man these things
are [ __ ] good they weren't like they
used to be uh was one called musa
and it was kind of a moose of the
warrior i think is what it's called that
was the english title
uh i think the uh
the korean title it translated as like
slave
and it was about this korean slave guy
who had been um he was traveling around
these korean mercenaries this is back in
the mid their medieval era and they were
on this damn mission to contact china
and it's kind of like their version of
saving private ryan they get [ __ ] up
it's it's a it's a real good one try
guys want to check that one out musa the
warrior yeah i don't think i've seen
that one actually it's really good i've
heard of it but i haven't seen it yeah
swords and bows and stuff and it's just
like real kind of realistic combat
uh medieval type combat that one i
noticed and then the one after that that
i really noticed was that uh
that old boy
yeah which we did a review of yeah and
actually the guy that's in this playing
the serial killer was also yeah that's
right that's right that is the same guy
yes it is and um
when i saw old boy
it has style it had pretty decent
storytelling you know it was
and it was kind of set itself apart from
a lot of japanese stuff it did kind of
have a japanese kind of flavor to it but
you could tell it was it was real good
quality well this one came out in 2010
and you watch it and this is like
this is kind of like the korean version
of i don't know
silence of the lambs or no not really
more kind of like uh
hannibal rising
it's kind of like that
this dude who's like a cop who's like
really [ __ ] he's actually kind of a
secret agent like a cia
he's nis is what he is yeah kind of like
their version fbi type of deal yeah and
uh
he's really resisting he's really
resisting the urge to become a serial
killer
of serial killers kind of like dexter
yeah dexter but not funny or like
not funny at all yeah
and um
also kind of like
um
hannibal rising which is one of my
favorite hannibal lecter movies
uh it's a real stylish good movie
and it's kind of like
shows that had a lecture in a weird way
was kind of like batman when he started
out
or a dude like this
you know trying to get revenge for what
happened to his his sister and his
family and that's what
eventually made him into a cannibal
this this movie's kind of like that oh
it's worth seeing i liked it i enjoyed
it i i actually first saw this movie
probably two or three years ago after i
saw it on kind of
underrated horror movies it's usually
classified as a horror movie which it's
not exactly it's more like a revenge
thriller but it definitely has
like some horror elements for sure and
it is about a serial killer and there is
uh
this is way more violent than most
horror movies that you would see it's
got a lot of action in it a lot of
action sequences yeah it's kind of like
an action movie too
yeah it definitely is so it has that so
i saw it like a few years ago and it
like turned up on some like it was like
rolling stone list or something like
that like these underrated horror movies
and so i saw that it was on shutter at
that time and i watched and i was like
holy [ __ ] that was [ __ ] great
and i kept like wanting him to watch it
and then like you know we just never got
around to it and then finally last night
it's on amazon prime if you have amazon
prime you can watch it for free and i
was like well we're gonna watch it
tonight goddammit because i've been
wanting to see this for a while and it
was still early in the evening because
it's kind of long i will admit that it's
two and a half hours so it is kind of
like a time commitment although i will
say it two and a half hours it doesn't
seem like it dragged at all oh no i was
instantly pulled into it
i liked it immediately i didn't you know
what i mean it wasn't those kind of
moves you have to kind of like wait and
warm up to
i i immediately was like oh this is a
good movie
yeah you can kind of tell like right
from the outset i mean and not only that
it's just kind of like this was directed
by um kim ji woon who has done a lot of
movies but i think probably his best
known one over here is a tale of two
sisters uh which is also great although
it's a lot different than this one tale
of two sisters is kind of more like a
traditional
ghost story
you know horror movie whereas this one
like i said is way more like action
movie revenge thriller serial killer
type story and it also kind of has
it has kind of like a moral undertone to
it and i think one of the things that
really makes this work and this is
something that makes a lot of kind of
other korean movies that i really got
into like trying to boost on for example
they're very good
uh you know the the kind of like
top-tier south korean directors are
really good at getting you emotionally
invested in their characters
without having to do too much
uh exposition or too much and i'm not
really sure how they do it but
they did it the way that uh real
traditional good hollywood directors did
it but by quality storytelling and you
know showing and not telling and being
kind of linear see a lot of problems
with
japanese storytelling is that it's not
real linear it's kind of episodic and it
jumps around they're they're it's not
kind of
western storytelling is kind of based on
what you'd find from like
uh you know uh shakespeare there's a
beginning there's a middle and there's a
ant
you know i mean it's pretty clearly
constructed and easy to follow a lot of
japanese stuff jumps all over the place
too many downfalls it's episodic too
like i've noticed right well
not across the board but
koreans you know back in the 60s and the
70s
were trying to kind of emulate what
japanese did and
it's really hard to do that right they
mostly do it wrong because it just
usually sucks
and the koreans knew that too and so the
japanese all their good directors are
kind of like
inspired by
western storytelling now there's some
exceptions you know and
[ __ ] kurosawa was real good you know
he he influenced a lot of american
uh uh uh directors and storytellers he
was kind of ahead of his time
but kurosawa also was basically
retelling shakespeare a lot of times
so you know there was an east west
exchange when it came to storytelling
this one has a very western
feel to it very western well it's a very
straightforward
story there's not there's not really any
jumping backward in time there's not
really any flashbacks really uh it's a
very very straightforward story it's not
um in a way that it's like it's no it's
not really any like twists and turns or
anything like that it's just kind of
like a steadily escalating yeah uh
situation is basically what it is yeah
and you're like oh you're you're like oh
this thing's just getting started
yeah he actually said that out loud at
one point okay i got you yeah
see which way they're going it's good
they're really good
honestly i [ __ ] love this movie so
okay so in case you guys don't know this
is what this is what happens in this
movie
um so
the guy who's kind of like the hero of
it he's played by lee bien khan who was
in a lot of stuff but most recently i
think he was in squid game
um and so he's like an nis agent which
is kind of like cia fbi type person so
at the very beginning he's talking to
his fiancee on the phone and her car has
broken down like on this sort of remote
word he's working somewhere he's in like
this motel hotel room or whatever with a
bunch of other agents
and her car is broken down um they kind
of established it's her birthday and
he's kind of like oh i'm always working
on your birthday i'm so sorry blah blah
blah and she's sitting there waiting for
the tow truck
and uh
sooner or later this little school bus
comes along it's a little school van i
guess
and the guy's like hey i can help you
you just have a flat tire and she's like
no bra that's okay i'm just like waiting
for the tow truck and she's really
nervous as you would be uh and she had
every right to be because it turns out
that this dude is a serial killer
and uh he
beats the [ __ ] out of her with a hammer
drags her back to his
lair
and it's implied that he rapes her later
although they don't show that and then
he cuts her into pieces and dumps all
the pieces in the thing
so uh so the guy so not only was her
fiance she was pregnant also by the way
um not only was her fiance like an fbi
type an nis agent but her dad was also
kind of like the chief of police of like
that area
so at this point um you know both of
them are just obviously devastated they
find her [ __ ] head it's horrifying
so he basically says i am going to he
resolves that i'm going to find the
person that did this and cause them the
same amount of pain that you caused to
her
so the rest of the movie because he's
you know a secret agent essentially and
he knows the chief of police who's also
the victim's dad
um he has access to all of this
information and technology and [ __ ] like
that so he decides what he's going to do
he's not just going to track this
[ __ ] down
and kill him
he's going to
essentially do like a cat and mouse
thing where he'll so he'll like catch
him for a little while and then beat the
[ __ ] out of him and like torture him and
[ __ ] like that and then let him go
just so he can like find him again
because he wants him to
feel the same fear yeah and the same uh
you know angst and stress and everything
that he caused to all of his victims now
this angle is kind of [ __ ] up because
he catches this dude lets him go and the
dude he lets the good dude go he goes
out rapes and kills other people well
see that's what i'm saying that well
that's kind of like the point of the
movie
is that this guy is the hero and you
understand what he's doing and the you
know the dude is a is a monster like you
know the serial killer is a monster um
he has like no redeeming qualities
whatsoever he's just a horrible like
sociopathic
person so it's like you don't feel bad
when he gets his ass thrashed uh you
know but
as it goes on
there's all of these sort of unintended
consequences like you know ripples in a
pond going out where
it probably would have been better if he
was going to do that because at first it
seemed like the cops kind of knew what
he was doing but they were sort of like
looking the other way they don't really
say that but that's kind of what they
implied
but once it starts getting to a thing
where
he gets into like this
almost like a cop it's not like a
competition but
bloodlust like yeah like this bloodlust
type thing where he's just like obsessed
with like going after the student like
making him suffer
and uh then like so the serial killer
almost starts to kind of like enjoy it
like enjoy the game because he's also a
hunter yeah so they become sort of like
more like each other i guess
yeah but in the meantime he's trying to
get his revenge
and enjoying his revenge but this dude
he's letting him go he's killing and
raping people
yeah well i mean the thing about it is
that at some point like the first time
that he catches him he actually prevents
because this guy like i said this guy
is
he's basically he gets fired from his
job because they find out that he's
under investigation for something
because the cops he is actually a
suspect it's just they didn't have
enough proof or whatever so he's been
you know tracked by the cops and so he
gets fired from his job as a school bus
driver so he decides that he's going to
kidnap like the last girl that's on the
bus like she's a teenager or whatever
and he takes her back to the lair and
he's like gonna rape her in a very very
hard to watch scene it's very disturbing
and he um that's when like the
the nis guy
uh he you know shows up so he prevents
that from happening
but
uh later on
because he let the dude go
just so he could have this
elaborate revenge on him um
other people do get
killed like murdered and what he wants
one girl gets raped
i don't think he kills her though he
prevented that but that wouldn't have
happened had he just killed the dude
outright in the very beginning yeah and
then
i think he ends up killing in the
commission of this [ __ ] a couple of
other people
die
when he when that agent could have
prevented all that just by killing him
outright on the very first [ __ ] day
yeah see so
it is a selfish thing and he seems to
not really have a big problem with the
fact that well that woman you know that
he didn't really care about it well yeah
that's kind of and like i said that's
kind of like what the theme of the movie
is is that he's in his they're not
saying necessarily that he's as bad as
the serial killer but
as the more it goes on he's getting to a
point where he almost could be as bad
because he's getting the point where all
these other people are like getting hurt
yeah and he almost like doesn't care
because he so wants revenge i promised
you know my dead fiance that i was going
to make him suffer the same way that he
made her suffer yeah and so all of these
people that are like you know collateral
damage he forgets all about preventing
crime and protected people yeah so
that's what i'm saying and then they
even have like a thing in there where
like the guy they're the where the um
the victim's dad who's also the chief of
police and the victim's sister basically
beg him to stop they're like look we
know who he is now the cops know who he
is we get it um you know we would like
to do that too but it's like you are
turning into a monster just like him and
you really need to stop it because this
is gonna have unforeseen consequences
and indeed it does and honestly like at
the very very end
how it ends like with him just like
walking away and like his kind of like
sob crying and stuff is he almost seems
to like realize
i've become
you know all just as bad as him yeah
it's it's um oscar it's on for it's on
free for him on amazon it's on amazon
prime uh at the moment for free if you
want to watch it murder hornet keeps
saying tom 200 or it's your ass no that
[ __ ] is going to be your ass
you're trying to sell some ass i don't
want your ass
just got all them down [ __ ] zits and
[ __ ] on the [ __ ] booty shave that
[ __ ] ew
yeah uh john gorra says they're shades
of dirty hairy and i saw the devil yeah
it is and i'm gonna say too um
this is not this movie is no joke okay
so like the violence in this
it's not even
it's gory
but it's not it's that kind of violence
where
it's really realistic and it's just kind
of like i mean
that one scene where he like cuts open
that dude's achilles tendon yeah
um
is
really
really difficult to watch and the ones
one of my favorite scenes in it actually
as far as like violence and stuff is the
one scene where the serial killer gets
picked up
by those two other guys in the taxi
who i didn't even realize this until i
went and read the wikipedia synopsis
but one of those guys that's in the taxi
because obviously those guys were
criminals too
one of the other guys in the taxi was
the fourth suspect
the one that he didn't get to
and i was like oh i didn't realize
because i hadn't got like a real good
look at that guy's picture because he
never did like go and check out that guy
because he found the actual killer like
the third time around
so because there was four suspects and
he kind of like went down the list like
trying to figure out who it was that
actually killed his girlfriend so um
yeah so that scene where he gets picked
up in the car and he like immediately
knows these two dudes are two more
predators and him just like [ __ ]
i don't even know how they [ __ ] shot
this but it's just kind of like this
spiraling kind of thing like around the
inside of this car and him just like
stabbing the [ __ ] out of like the dude
in the driver's seat and the dude in the
back seat it's amazing yeah and there's
just [ __ ] blood spraying everywhere
holy crap this is this is a great movie
oh it's fantastic i love this definitely
definitely definitely one of one of the
one of the best korean movies i've seen
definitely oh yeah it's got its own
character and everything it's up there
trying to train to busan and musa and
and like an old boy old boy actually if
you like old boy you'd probably [ __ ]
love it yeah yeah yeah
this is better than old boy if you ask
me honestly i like i i love old boy but
i think i like this better yeah um and
another thing too i want to
i will i will bring up the turd scene i
promise yeah but um
everybody says turn c no no yeah but um
i want to say too like the
cinematography in this is
beautiful
i love the juxtaposition between
the serial killer like with all his warm
tones they have all that kind of thing
and then like the background is kind of
like these teal kind of it's just really
really nice looking but not overtly
stylized but it is like really nice
looking all the shots and everything
yeah there's this one scene in this
ironically
uh this movie is full of like rape and
dismemberment and violence and people's
arms being snapped and broken and
killers knowing each other and
cannibalism and yeah cannibalism like
people being cut up and everything like
that um and what i was gonna say certain
parts of this movie
now they're not quite as far as like
devil's rejects or thousands of thousand
corpses but you could
there is like some of that kind of
dynamic like serial killers that hang
out with one another and do [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] in front of each other
there's that kind of stuff
yeah it was like yes it's like hey bro i
know this other serial killer although i
thought did they mention i thought he
was his brother
but was he not i don't i didn't catch
they didn't really look alike yeah i
didn't catch that part that might be i
was like maybe he just called him that
just at like
they were saying like he's one of us
they were talking about
they believed that the the uh the fbi
agent that was after him that they they
believed he was a serial killer he was
one yeah because he had he was doing the
same kind of [ __ ] that they did yeah um
yeah so there's a scene in here where
near the beginning like the first time
that the nis agent um
captures the serial killer and beats the
[ __ ] out of him and [ __ ] up his
achilles tendon and breaks his arm i
think he breaks his arm or breaks his
wrist
and he knocks him out
um and he makes him swallow this uh
tracker it's a tracker and has a
microphone on it so he can kind of hear
uh hear him talking and he can like uh
see where he is
now the serial killer can't doesn't
figure out for a long time how this dude
keeps finding him right because he's
trying to like get away and he's just
like how the [ __ ] does he keep like
turning up but eventually
he overhears him talking so he like
knows
oh it's in his stomach right
so there's this one scene where he goes
to a pharmacy and gets a whole [ __ ] ton
of laxatives
and then and you saw because i'd seen
this movie before so it's like as soon
as he goes in and gets all the laxatives
i'm like yeah i'm going in the other
room for a minute because i remember the
scene
and it's like i can watch people being
like cut into pieces and [ __ ] like that
all day long but anything having to do
with poop i'm out you gotta dig in there
find a tracker man yeah he had to like
give himself diarrhea so he could like
dig and then he like washes it off and
like puts it in another dude yeah you
know what i mean that he like beat the
[ __ ] up and it's the grossest [ __ ]
[ __ ] ever and it's just kind of like
that's that kind of stuff grosses me out
like where i'm like kind of almost on
the verge of gagging just thinking about
it
well i mean to me that kind of stuff
bothers me like i said it was in your
mind i mean you know it's not it's not
[ __ ] he's not really digging around
and [ __ ] it looked like it but it was
fake you know yeah that's what i'm
saying see i'm gagging already yeah just
thinking about it
it's just it's so [ __ ] gross but yeah
it's just like the crest [ __ ] scene
but it's like i can watch people get
stabbed and like get their heads cut off
and [ __ ] like that all day but i don't i
can't watch that poop stuff that just
grosses me out a lot
um yeah it's just
danny rolly goes face says i hope you
guys review scream when it comes out oh
the new one
we got as soon as the [ __ ] we gotta go
watch [ __ ] uh spiderman too yeah
maybe we can go thursday or saturday or
something yeah i want to go during the
weekdays when it's not so [ __ ]
crowded like it was last time we went
there yeah we get some we'll get some
food and [ __ ] john goris says the bid
the bit with the fishing hooks got to me
see it's always kind of like little [ __ ]
like that you know what i mean where
it's just kind of like i said this isn't
like a super super gore it is gory but
it's not like
i don't know i i want to say it's not
like torture porn but it is kind of but
just the violence that they show is so
realistic and so
and i have to say too that
they don't really like cut away the way
a lot of movies would
the one scene toward the end where
where somebody gets like beheaded like
in a makeshift uh guillotine
um normally they would like cut away and
then spill like the fake head or
anything but they don't do that so it
looks
real you know what i mean yeah they did
their homework you know they studied
movies and like you know how we're gonna
get this done you know these these guys
these these directors know what they're
doing little t you know koreans are good
now they know how to make [ __ ]
yeah i mean so i mean if you haven't
seen this movie and you really like the
revenge like i said if you liked old boy
or anything like that then you would
probably [ __ ] love this
um
it's just the interactions between
the guy and the serial killer
it's almost kind of like it's it's a sad
it's almost kind of like tragic because
not only has revenge made you know the
good guy
into a monster
but
they're kind of leaving you to imply
that
he's he can he could have never won
because the serial killer will never
learn or he will never feel bad for what
he did because he's not capable of it if
you like that new korean series there's
a lot of that kind of tone in this what
was that what squid game squid game yeah
and actually the guy that plays the main
character the nis he i think he was in
squid game as well i don't i don't know
remember if it was like
because i'm yeah that's right he was in
that yeah that's right the guy from
training
it's a different story but the writing
and the tone is you know it's like that
and someone's just serial killers
yeah i mean this is way darker than
squid game
well they've crunched it into a little
small area and it's got a lot of violent
action film it's like it's like squid
game and
it's like squid game and old boy and
[ __ ] silence the lamps and it's like
and everything's all just kind of one
movie it's pretty good yeah i mean it's
it's pretty [ __ ] like it's pretty
[ __ ] up i thought you would yeah
that's why that's why i was like kept
bugging you to watch it and then finally
last night it was like all right we're
watching this god damn it it's action
horror
yeah action horror like i said i kind of
feel like it gets you know put into
horror yeah black action or it is more
like a revenge like an action thriller
but i wouldn't be mad about it if
somebody put it in horror if somebody
calls it horror i don't i don't think
you're wrong about it um oscar perez
says i would love if you guys review the
cook the thief his wife and her lover
jenny i know you've seen it yes i have
sounds uh but tom you would consider it
a masterpiece i would really actually
want to see that again because i
remember really really liking that the
first time that was gosh no um
i want to say it was late 80s or early
90s but i can't remember now when the
[ __ ] did i see that
maybe it's newer than i thought
hmm i remember seeing it i think i saw
it in the early 90s or the mid 90s so it
was sometime around there but maybe like
earlier
um you should see sallow then yeah i've
seen that as well yeah
like i said i honestly i just got to a
point where i was younger i couldn't
watch anything uh in movies that had to
do with vomit
and
i still can't it depending but um it
doesn't bother me as much now but i
still can't watch poop stuff honestly i
can't even watch that scene in um train
spotting where the dude climbs in the
toilet and it's like i can't even watch
that without
i mean i can watch it but i'll just sit
there and go
just like for [ __ ] 10 minutes
afterwards like while i'm thinking about
it nothing like nothing else in movies
bothers me except for that kind of stuff
i don't know why just 89. thank you if
uh the cook the thief is like for wife
in her lover was 89. yeah i thought it
was late 80s because i remember seeing
it around there but uh but yeah so
seriously if you haven't seen
i saw the devil it's so [ __ ] good
it's so [ __ ] good
um you know it's just the acting is
amazing the cinematography is amazing
it's super violent it's fun it's super
[ __ ] up it's pretty [ __ ] up
so if you don't like [ __ ] up [ __ ] then
you probably won't like it but if you do
like [ __ ] up [ __ ] then you should see
it because it's really good but uh yeah
i guess that's it right
is that all you that you had to say
about that that's all i had to say
that's all i have to say about that
you're being all like forrest gumpy i'm
just gonna end up repeating myself
see it that's good
yeah like i said it's on amazon prime it
might might be on to be at the moment
but i'm not entirely sure so don't quote
me on that but we just watch it on
amazon prime like for free so definitely
definitely watch it uh alright so we
gonna wrap it up yep all right so we'll
be back tomorrow
uh
we're gonna do another movie oh
i should say this because i said this on
the thing yesterday remember because we
were late yesterday because i said oh i
ordered food and it didn't show up and
everything
so after we did the stream
i said well i'm gonna order some chinese
food goddamn it we're gonna go down and
get it so the minute we opened the door
to go down to get the chinese food the
domino's food was on our
doorstep like on our porch yeah and
it hadn't been there like before we did
the stream because i checked nobody rang
the doorbell
nobody knocked at the door nope nobody
texted me or called me or anything and
said the food was there so the sandwich
was full of ants yep
you got it for free though
yeah i mean i had cancelled it yeah so i
don't know what the [ __ ] salad was
sealed it had shrimp not sure
it was shrink-wrapped and it was in a
bag so the salad was okay yeah but the
sandwich was just like in a cardboard
box and you know was full of ants so i
couldn't eat it but the salad was fine i
ate that so you know [ __ ] dominoes when
for delivery that's up the street anyway
right there and get it that's true i
just didn't feel like going anywhere
because i was busy and i was just kind
of like well help wanted signs out here
around for all that stuff i think they
there's a lot of turnovers they might
not have a lot of delivery drivers yeah
maybe that's why it's like
problems remember that
they're having problems with delivery
they always need those damn delivery
drivers
which [ __ ] man why would you want why
would you want to burn up your own car
for for that yeah i mean delivering
pizzas is just kind of like it's seems
like a i would only do it if you're in
like a high density area and you could
use a motorcycle with your damn
box on the back because and you want you
don't want a big bike you want like a
250 that gets a 125 miles an hour down
you know 125 miles to a gallon because
then you wouldn't spend all your money
in [ __ ] gasoline
i mean honestly if you were going to be
a delivery driver you might as well do
something like grubhub or ubereats or
something like that and then you could
just like deliver for lots of things
right yeah
although
he probably uh i don't think he i don't
think you make a [ __ ] well it depends
where you live i mean if you live in a
high density area without a lot of other
drivers then you can make okay money i
think but
you still have to pay
usually i think you have to i think some
of the companies give you like a gas
i can't remember which company's problem
is your experience allowance yeah your
auto auto expenses and the [ __ ] hours
yeah they're constantly running your
[ __ ] ragged and if you're in a high
density area where all the money is
chances are you're in a high crime area
too those dudes get [ __ ] robbed yeah
it just seems like it's not worth it
this is out in the country so
everything's far you you want a little
motorcycle that gets great gas mileage
yeah because [ __ ] out here i can imagine
this dominant i mean there's some houses
around here but you probably have to
drive really far like for a delivery
probably in a damn 10 mile square and
it's a lot of these [ __ ] little roads
are hard but now they have gps so it'd
be a lot easier than it used to you
could plot a course
yeah you'd have like nine deliveries to
do and you could [ __ ] plot them all
probably get them all in the right order
too if you got good enough that gps well
yeah i got a badass garmin [ __ ] if
you go right there on my damn handlebars
but you don't want like a thousand cc or
1200 cc motorcycle like mine you want
like a 250
because you know the priority isn't
speed priority is gas economy yeah and
no expenses you know
if
real cheap insurance and stuff
real cheap running costs
car would just eat you up just dumb
nowadays just
yeah camp guy said i used to have a
chinese restaurant that had the owner
guy or his kid from the restaurant that
delivered honestly i think the chinese
place up here delivers but i imagine
it's only over a certain amount and it
doesn't because it looks like they only
have like two or three people working
there it's pretty small but it's so
close it's just you just run out there
yeah and i mean i just order online and
then go up there and get it so that's
what i had yesterday because i was like
well domino's didn't bring me anything
so
i was like really starving but uh yeah
all right so we'll figure out a movie to
watch this evening maybe we'll do i'm
going to write this down because
otherwise i'll forget if
the cook the thief maybe we'll all watch
that tonight because if if we can find
it for
not terribly expensive maybe we can
watch that tonight and talk about that
tomorrow uh but yeah have a good rest of
your afternoon you guys and we'll see
you guys tomorrow afternoon
bye